warning this video might be too hot to
handle tell me about some of the
negative things you've heard about
female genitalia before face cut and
loosey-goosey smells like fish oh that
girl's stinks
move over love is blind take a hike
bachelor Netflix's latest reality show
makes even Jessica look like a saint too
hot to handle is a roller coaster of
trash so join me as we explore this
beautiful train wreck now you know it's
gonna be a good show when it starts with
a font just as obnoxious as the show
itself obviously we found the hottest
horniest commitment-phobic swipe stirs
ooh tell me more no this isn't an
infomercial for a 24-hour sex line this
is a reality show with a twist
contestants share a prize of $100,000
but that number lowers every time one of
them breaks the rules that means no
kissing no kissing that's it no heavy
petting or sex of any kind that includes
no self-gratification
[Music]
should have knocked one out yesterday
but enough about the rules let's meet
the host in our contestants here's Lana
and anagram for anal because she's a
pain in the ass she's from a factory in
China because the show couldn't afford
an actual host her job is basically to
watch the contestants and keep an eye on
them in case they engage in any sexual
activity so basically she's my creepy
uncle on to the contestants meet Chloe
from Essex quite ditzy as well so you've
just gotta be really patient with me
because I'm not the brightest spark and
in the book you don't say I also want to
point out here that the show doesn't
bother telling us what the contestants
do for a living it doesn't matter next
is sure on the shows Kevin Hart
seriously look how short he is hi a
feminist yes I study women in gender
studies at college you know that's
pretty refreshing to see a man
interested in women's issues kind of get
the blueprint into how to pick up women
oh yes I just actually signed up for
Christian mingle what I'm most proud of
is my penis I have this picture and it's
measured next to air freshener King
next is hailey a sorority girl who
doesn't even know the language of her
own tattoo weed that stupid ah meet
David from the UK and Harry from
Australia David is the quintessential
British gentleman and does what any
British gentleman would do upon arriving
and immediately lathers the girls and
sunscreen Harry on the other hand tells
us about his favorite pastime DMing
Instagram celebrities so I've hit
everyone famous ivy I'm like Kourtney
Kardashian
Kendall I hit it with the hello my
little bottle chicken can you believe
the butter chicken line never works next
up is Francesca usually if a guy's hot
and I want him it's just like do a
little hair flip just like make eye
contact and it's game over as you can
tell she doesn't care about her looks at
all in steps Matthew wearing a dress and
a beanie in 30-degree weather is it like
a religious thing or he'll come to
affectionately be known as Jesus and we
have Jesus next are Nicole and Ronda my
ideal type of guy they need to have a
job the bar is high gentlemen and how
about Nicole the lies that I've been
dating within like three dates they tell
me that they're like falling for me and
then I'm like you know then I just give
them the snake in our final contestant
hailing all the way from the UK Kells
r32 relationships Jen goes for me has
never really been a problem you know
he's like the guy you want to bring home
to mom well as our contestants get to
know each other it's only a matter of
hours before the real game begins the
guests are ushered into the palapa where
Lana explains the rules and the purpose
of the game the purpose of this retreat
is to help you gain deeper emotional
connections in your personal
relationships and just look at Harry's
reaction here he looks like he's gonna
die with the game officially begun at a
new day dawning Lana decides to throw
some curve balls to encourage the guests
to form deeper connections these include
dates workshops and grenades
with grenades no not those grenades as
the show progresses new contestants will
be brought in to blow things up and test
their commitment to the game and each
other but we'll get into that in a bit
finally we have the ultimate test the
private suite where couples who show
growth can spend the night in the
ultimate test of chastity well it didn't
take long for our first rule break Harry
and Francesca lasted a measly few hours
and kiss and Harry being the absolute
gentleman says the whole sound logic but
it's when Harry tells the boys about
what he did that things start to get a
little messy I was you just cost me
three holidays three nights in the
results let's rewind the footage ah she
kissed you okay looking real vulnerable
there the guests gather in the palapa
where Alana tells them that Harry and
Francesca's kiss costs them three
thousand dollars but what's even more
hilarious is that Harry blames Francesca
and lies about the whole thing you
kissed me I didn't kiss you you said why
don't we just go now because the money
doesn't matter in my position I thought
I should kiss me heaven she feels like I
kissed her it's like do you not know
cameras are recording this later that
evening Chloe and David go on a romantic
date to explore their connection and
Chloe here miss hygienic uses her own
damn figures double dipping them into
the chocolate double dip the chip
she even rubs the chocolate around her
nipples I mean maybe some guys find that
hot I don't know your one-night stand
type of guy
[Music]
as their connection grows Fran and
Hayley devise a plan to get back at the
group for not believing Fran's side of
the hairy kissing controversy they
decide to make out losing the group
another $3,000 what could go wrong the
next day the group had their first
workshop to help them steer away from
meaningless hookups and toward
meaningful relationships and what better
way to do this than by tying each other
up this is the ancient art of shabari
what's it called
Shambhala G Chiron here seems to have
the right idea producers pair up harry
and francesca who currently hate each
other but it isn't long before they
patched things up the group is then
brought together and told of the latest
rule break a couple has kissed and cost
the group three thousand dollars and for
the time being it looks like Haley and
Franz plan seems to work but it's
Michael who's on to them the most
manipulative person in the house is
hanging out with the most mindless human
on earth does anyone see any issues I
like the international vibe Harry from
Australia and I literally have no idea
where that is Rhonda expresses her
concerns over her relationship with
Chiron because he isn't opening up to
her he says that's because his ex
cheated on him with his best friend you
gotta understand I've been so starved
for my past days just like I don't give
people opportunity Rhonda says she can't
handle this and breaks things off with
him because she feels he's not
emotionally available and honest with
her funny since she hides the fact she
has a son and doesn't even tell him til
the second last episode the group
gathers again to discuss the mystery of
the $3,000 kiss now I'm not sure why
they didn't do this before but
apparently you can just ask Lana who the
culprits were and they find out it was
Haley and Francesca as if these girls
couldn't be any more hated but to get
everyone's mind off things David brings
everyone out for a workout when they're
interrupted by
meet Bryce he lives on a houseboat the
last time I had sex was at the hotel
last night I probably have sex every day
I wake up with whoever she is then I'll
just think man I can't wait to go out
tonight and meet a different girl let's
see if his charm can woo these ladies
the next day the contestants get these
wristbands which can light up green
giving them a free pass to break the
rules the catch only when Lana believes
they're making progress in their
relationships will it change colors that
night the guests welcomed Bryce by
throwing him a party and he serenades
everyone with his mad piano skills can
just look at Kells wanting to kill
himself one lady however has taken a
liking to this new guy and they soon hit
things off we'll find out the next day
the contestants partake in a workshop
called without words where they have to
express their emotions using only their
body the women have to express
excitement and all I'm thinking is thank
God they didn't make the guys do this
David even full-on cries sparking some
jealousy from Sharon who thinks he's
making a move on Rhonda Francesca and
Harry still haven't discussed what's
going on with them are they a couple
what's the deal
so Francesca takes the opportunity to
explore things with Kells
but Kells has the mental fortitude of a
god and holds back her advances before
we have Israel still kiss
what you shut your mouth that man is a
hero when they're having totally not gay
workouts together David and Shirin
discussed their feelings for Rhonda
David will step aside if Chiron is
willing to put himself in that
vulnerable position with Rhonda and they
quickly patch things up and who could
forget this epic breakup where Francesca
tells kettle's they should just be
friends
I think we should just take a step back
and like stay friends for now cool we
sure are having the green light from
David he had Rhonda go on a romantic
date and get the green light smooth
they're the first couple that gets
invited to the private suite to test if
they can go the night without doing the
deed the next morning the contestants
wonder whether sure Rhonda bank but it's
Breck's who has his mind on something
else I looked at Khloe this morning and
I'm thinking hashtag blowy ah classy
Rhonda arrives and tells the girls that
she and chiron did not have sex
Sharan didn't want to risk blowing what
they have and instead wanted to focus on
growing their relationship meanwhile
this is how the guys reacted to the news
well I could poke a hole in the wall at
the palapa the group learns that
Sharonda may not have gone all the way
but they definitely did some other
naughty things the list of offenses
includes kissing inappropriate touching
of the constant use of their in the not
to mention the
costing the group a whopping $16,000 the
prize fund now stands at 78,000 that
night Chloe's hot and heavy for Bryce so
I'm not used to like a class of guys
hashtag glowy they kiss and a few inches
later I was just like oh I don't know
looks like Bryce is gonna have to get a
blowy somewhere else the guys have their
first all-male workshop where they rub
clay all over each other you can start
reading that in really real you know
cover that body hmm
then they must rate the things that are
holding them back and stab them with a
spear
and after this great bonding experience
where the men have really dug deep into
their emotions we get a great
slow-motion Beach shot where we can
objectify them fran and here he patched
things up and become six cluesive he
even says he doesn't want to break the
rules with her and just check out her
face when he says it I don't want to
break the rules
Lana also kicks out Haley from the show
for not growing enough through this
journey I mean can you blame Lana I
don't think I'm learning anything other
than everyone in this house is an idiot
and I don't think Lana's process is
doing anything for any of them either
because they're all stupid with Haley
gone the show gets its biggest shake-up
with the arrival of three new
contestants we have Lydia from the UK I
love sex
it makes me feel good and I don't think
anyone should be ashamed to say that
Corey from the UK move this way to
follow the rules what we gonna do read
the newspaper honestly I don't even
think he can read and then there's
Madison who gets less screen time than
Lana this entire season Francesca is
quite welcoming of the newcomers feeling
quite confident with her relationship
with Harry I nice to meet you by the way
don't try because I'll kill you and
Chloe fresh off her disastrous kiss with
Brice hits things off with Corey that
night Francesca and Harry get invited to
the private suite but can Harry keep it
in his pants wet let's just say the
private suite wasn't that private and
the guest learned the penalty for
Francesca and Harry's escapades is a
whopping 20 grand Francesca is priceless
to me
so $20,000 doesn't mean [ __ ] that might
actually be the sweetest thing he's said
all season Michael also decides to leave
just like Jesus he hasn't found that
romantic connection
Nicole decides to wear a garbage bag for
some reason and Chloe and Cory finally
make out
Lana later asked Cory who we would like
to ask on a date and totally blindsides
Chloe by choosing Francesca who is
already in a committed relationship to
make matters more complicated Francesca
agrees to the date Harry doesn't think
she'll do anything but this is the girl
who a few days ago tried to bang Kells
and made out with Hayley just to screw
the group over
you're such a troublemaker but we can
all breathe a sigh of relief because
Francesca stomps Cory's advances as much
as the temptation is like so real for
you I can't like jeopardize what the
girls also get their own workshop called
yoni pooja which is basically a vagina
exam to strengthen yourself and create a
bond of sisterhood with the other women
meanwhile this is what the guys are
doing the girls are instructed to paint
representations of their vaginas talk
about worse nudes ever
hey I'm just thankful they didn't make
the guys do this invigorated with the
power of her yoni Chloe tells Cory off
for leading her on and choosing
Francesca to go on a date with instead
of her openly tell them how you feel
Danny just like straight up walks away
and later that night Francesca gives
Harry a good ol blowy which is another
six K deducted from the prize total
bringing the grand prize down to 43
thousand dollars with things coming to
an end Lana will soon choose a winner
and decide how to divvy up the prize
money but not before some last-minute
dates Sheeran and Rhonda have
commandeered a boat somehow and sure
honest Rhonda to be his girlfriend the
guests hold a final party and are told
by Lana that Harry and Francesca the two
contestants who have lost the most money
from the pot have an opportunity to make
it back if they can last the night in
the private suite without touching each
other Lana will restore the money they
lost back into the pot Kells isn't too
confident in them moms we just fought
bankruptcy now yeah but it's Francesca
who asks the real important questions
Anil is in the private suite Harry
immediately cuffs himself to the chair
and it doesn't look like they're gonna
make it stop it
believe it or not Francesca and Harry
survived the night bringing the grand
prize to $75,000 and just before the
show ends
Lana informs Cory and Madison that they
haven't made enough progress and will be
booted let's face it Cory was a mega
douche with the IQ of a sea cucumber and
poor Madison didn't establish any
emotional connections with the other
guests and here it is ladies and
gentlemen what we've all been waiting
for
who will win that coveted prize money
first Francesca Harry Sharon and Rhonda
are asked to stand and as the tense
reality show music plays David is also
asked to stand then everyone else
everyone wins yay you see they've all
learned lessons in maturity inner
strength trust building emotional
connections and communication but above
all they've learned to love themselves
so each contestant walks away with a
valuable experience and $7,500 Francesca
even says I'm gonna be the new Lana for
all my friends that I'm gonna be
preaching these weird things to them and
I'm literally mother Teresa and I'm
gonna spread my knowledge to the world
and judging by her Instagram she makes
one hot mother Theresa thanks for
watching everyone if you liked this
video make sure to LIKE and subscribe
and check out my playlist of other
god-awful shows I'd also love to hear
what you thought of the season you can
also follow me on Twitter at things
story whitey until next time remember
daddy loves you very much